harlem désir le secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes est l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir soir merci d'être
avec nous 2015 sera peut-être pour vous
l'occasion d'être moins discret affable
désir c'est un voeu surtout en ce début
d'année qui voit donc à nouveau la zone
euro
secoué par l'incertitude politique en
grèce nous évoquerons bien sûr le retour
des fragilités de la monnaie commune
et puis ce succès qu'ont contesté en
allemagne mais également à bruxelles des
discours et des programmes anti
austérité pas seulement en grèce avec
karine perret de l' agence france-presse
notre partenaire comme chaque semaine
avec dailymotion bien sûr perrine
tarneaud sera également là comme chaque
semaine en fin d'émission et nous
évoquerons avec elle la situation du
parti socialiste donc vous avez cédé les
rênes il ya un peu moins d'un an
maintenant à jean christophe cambadélis
alors on verra enfin vous nous direz
s'il ya du mieux l'année s'annonce
hautement périlleuse avec deux élections
et un congrès mais on va d'abord évoqué
harlem désir françois hollande
le chef de l'état cherche à se relancer
ça va être le cas nous dit on tout au
mois de vente ou le mois de janvier mais
sans rien annoncé de neuf est seulement
possible mais d'abord le président de la
république a surtout montré qu'ils
avaient de la constance dans sa volonté
de redresser le pays de le faire avancer
effectivement il a adressé des voeux à
la fois de mobilisation mais aussi de
combat aux français et aux gouvernements
mais plus que cela en soulignant que
c'était en agissant dans la durée que
l'on pouvait faire ressortir le pays de
la situation dans laquelle on l'a trouvé
en arrivant mais le problème n'est pas
de chercher des excuses
il est justement de montrer qu'on peut
entrer dans ce nouveau monde faire face
aux grandes mutations de l'économie en
faisant en même temps avancées des
progrès sociaux et donc en même temps
que se met en oeuvre cette politique de
compétitivité le pacte de responsabilité
qui aiment nos entrevues en encore en
attend les résultats avec des tours
en oeuvre simplement et sans résultat
tangible pas dans la durée
on va se faire sortir par exemple la
dent dès cette rentrée le 1er janvier
les salariés embauchés au niveau du smic
dans les entreprises c'est sans charges
sociales le crédit d'impôt compétitivité
emploi passe à 6 % de baisse du coût du
travail jusqu'à 2,5 smic est
terriblement désir c'est que oui mais
les numérations mais on sait que ça ne
suffira pas à faire reculer derrière
justement c'était aussi des voeux de
volontarisme contre cette espèce de
déclinisme de défaitisme auquel il ne
faut pas se résigner
parce que comme l'a dit le président de
la république la france c'est un pays
qui a les capacités qui a les atouts
pour surmonter les défis dans lesquelles
nous sommes confrontés est un pays qui
compte c'est un pays quant à l'échelle
internationale c'est un pays qui compte
en europe
moi je le vois chaque jour chaque
semaine notamment quand j'accompagne le
président de la république dans ses
déplacements internationaux dans les
sommets de chefs d'état et de
gouvernement c'est un pays qui est au
coeur aujourd'hui de la résolution d'un
certain nombre de grandes crises par
exemple la crise entre l'ukraine et la
russie c'est le président de la
république qui a repris l'initiative
c'est un pays qui innove aussi il ya en
ce moment un salon des industries du qui
se passe aux etats unis
eh bien la france et ses start up compte
parmi les pays les mieux représentés
et c'est un pays qui peut aussi
continuer à incarner des valeurs et un
progrès social
quand par exemple nous mettons en oeuvre
le droit à la formation tout au long de
la vie avec le comte formation on va
bénéficier chaque salarié mais aussi
ceux qui sont en situation de chômage
quand nous mettons en oeuvre dans la
réforme des retraites
la prise en compte de la pénibilité pour
ceux qui sont exposés parce qu'il
travaille la grande et bien vous montrer
ses actifs en est une autre qui oui
qu'on peut faire les deux et le chant
peut on peut avancer sur le plan
économique et continuons dans cette
affaire de mon fils et les croissants
sur les douze derniers mois 180 mille
chômeurs de plus et on sait quelqu'un
pour cent de croissance françois
hollande dit espérer plus on arrivera
toujours pas à inverser la courbe alors
est-ce qu'on peut comme cela plaidé
tenir ce discours volontariste sans
mesures nouvelles sur pour le marché de
l'emploi
bien sûr il s'agit pas simplement de
plaider il faut agir et le défi numéro
un c'est celui que vous avez mentionné
c'est évidemment celui de l'emploi c'est
pourquoi tous les efforts
la loi sur l'activité la croissance
présentées par le
l'économie emmanuel macron à la loi la
loi du siècle les mesures que nous
défendons au plan européen
oui mais il a dit aussi que c'était une
loi qui préparait le siècle dans lequel
nous entrons c'est à dire qu'il doit
libérer les activités qui doit permettre
à des jeunes par exemple de rentrer dans
les professions qui sont aujourd'hui
très protégée et qui doit permettre que
des grands projets d'aménagement puisse
se mettre en oeuvre dans des délais
beaucoup plus rapide tout en gardant nos
normes environnementales aux normes
sociales mais oui mais vous faire des
affaires parce qu'alors vous avez vu la
charge
inouï de cécile duflot d'ailleurs on
constate que les assauts les plus
violents viennent de la gauche harlem
désir vous pourrez voyager à ça mais
enfin l'ancienne ministre du logement 1
cécile duflot veut mettre en échec la
loi macron c'est un grand retour en
arrière dit elle
vous ne me donnez pas un peu gv elle
aussi ne lui monte pas que j'ai vu aussi
quand vous dites qu'on vivra plus
facilement mener à bien des projets
alors question pourquoi est pourquoi il
s'est toujours composer le fait à la
fois de libérer la création d'activités
économiques le fait de s'adapter au
rythme de l'économie d'aujourd'hui à des
changements et le fait de défendre une
ambition écologique
cette année ça va être aussi celle de la
mise en oeuvre de la loi de transition
énergétique pour laquelle la france est
aujourd'hui un pays pionnier à l'échelle
de l'europe avec la réduction des gaz à
effet de serre avec l'isolation
thermique des monuments l'efficacité
énergétique des flots oui la montée en
puissance des énergies renouvelables
dans tous ces domaines
la france va être leader et elle va
accueillir à la fin de l'année vous le
savez la grande conférence paris climat
quand il va nous permettre d'avoir un
accord international
et c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'ont souligné
d'autres leaders écologistes comme
françois de rugy le président du mc ça
va être assez justement pourquoi des
écologistes que
le gouvernement peut se passer de leur
présence en cette année importante avec
la perspective de cette conférence
climat à la fin de l'année faut-il les
faire revenir doivent-ils revenir au
gouvernement c'est votre souhait vous
harlem désir
ils ont fait il avait dirigé beaucoup de
négociations avec louis mais ils ont
fait un choix et maison partagée
ils ont une discussion je crois qu'ils
se prononceraient tiges et j'avais
parviennent jeune et je n'ai pas à m'en
occuper je suis pas dans ces fonctions
là mais je constate que nous travaillons
avec eux que la loi de transition
énergétique nous l'avons adopté avec eux
aujourd'hui sur beaucoup de sujets
évidemment il participe à la vie de la
majorité dont je crois il considère
qu'ils sont toujours nombre bien on a
parlé de temps que de françois hollande
certains avaient évoqué certains de vos
collègues d'ailleurs eu une primaire
pour françois hollande
vous qui avez organisé 16/02/2011 ça
vous paraît crédible aujourd'hui pour
l'état sortant franchement enfin moi je
suis membre du gouvernement
les sujets qui nous mobilise ce qui
mobilise le président la république ce
sont ceux que vous avez évoqué est à
lire l'encadré
à votre arrivée quelques semaines
thierry mandon votre collègue chargé de
la simplification
c'est lui qui a mis sur la table
l'hypothèse et il a dit que la primaire
serait incontournable pour françois
hollande
mais là c'est vraiment à mille lieues
des préoccupations des français
aujourd'hui on parlait de la reprise de
l'activité dans des secteurs où on a
besoin aujourd'hui de croissance le
logement par exemple les mesures que
nous prenons en semaine je parlais de la
transition énergétique
tout ce que va permettre comme comme
travaux le fait d'isoler aujourd'hui les
bâtiments et les logements y compris
avec des aides européennes
j'aimerais que que l'on parle de cela
voilà les sujets qui nous mobiliser et
qui me préoccupe bon on sait quand même
que la réélection de occupe un peu
l'esprit de françois hollande non mais
françois hollande
il est totalement déterminée se jettent
abreu dressement il y aura un moment en
2017 ou ces questions pourront être
posées une somme en 2015 nous sommes au
coeur de l'action de ceux conquis de ce
quinquennat et cette année c'est une
année de concrétisation de la mise en
oeuvre de cette politique de
redressement économique de progrès
social de de redressement de notre
activité répond oui parce que
prenons le pacte de responsabilité
prenons la loi de transition énergétique
prenons les nouvelles mesures pour la
construction de logements
elles ont été adoptées maintenant lagon
l'entraîneur et c'est cela qui connaît
on est pas encore hélas ça dans la
deuxième partie du quinquennat qui
prévoyait selon les promesses de
françois hollande
le temps de la redistribution si vous en
parle de peut-être de concrétisation
mais la redistribuer ya aussi des
mesures de redistribuer vers juste quand
par exemple la première tranche de
l'impôt sur le revenu est supprimée et
que donc 9 millions de français vont
pouvoir ne pas être assujettis à cette
imposition c'est une redistribution de
pouvoir d'achat
quand nous évoquions tout à l'heure le
la prise en compte de la pénibilité le
fait que chaque salarié va pouvoir
comptabiliser les années où les mois
pendant lesquels il est exposé se dire
qu'il peut partir à la retraite pour
ceux qui sont concernés
plus tôt c'est une mesure de justice
sociale et de redistribution qui permet
à la fois de financer les retraites
parce qu'il a fallu prendre en compte
l'allongement de la durée de la vie
moyenne mais aussi le prendre en compte
le fait que pour certaines catégories
laura particulier d'ouvrier il y à des
expositions et donc il doit y avoir une
mesure de justice avec des écoutes mais
j'ai dans l'oreille ce qu'a dit manuel
valls à la toute fin d'année un journal
espagnol el mundo qui l'a sacré homme
politique de l'année vous l'avez entendu
employé lui fussent pas ce qu'il a dit
il a dit qu'il y aurait des années de
sacrifices pour les français des années
sacrifices alors hein c'est pas la
concrétisation est encore voilà c'est de
dire qu' on ne peut pas promettre que
les sacrifices
il va falloir les arrêter tout de suite
à quoi parce que parce que les garanties
pour les avaient calées oui mais parce
qu'il va falloir continuer encore à
faire des efforts par exemple nous
sommes lancés dans une grande réforme de
l'état
c'est à la fois la réforme territoriale
la réforme de la carte des régions mais
surtout de la redistribution des
compétences entre les agglomérations les
départements les nouvelles grandes
régions
là ça va impliquer aussi une réforme de
l'état donc il y à des efforts il ya des
changements km ça veut pas dire
forcément des régressions
ça veut dire aux confrères du progrès
mais avec c'est vrai une maîtrise de la
dépense publique avec de la
simplification avec un effort parce que
nous nous sommes dans une économie où
doit être compétitif vous avez gardez
vos lunettes roses en ce début d'année
2015 harlem désir
mais parce qu'il fout et non pas quand
vous dites que vous promener à
l'étranger qu'à chaque fois on vous
renvoie une image d'une france qui
réussit iliaque et que cela quand vous
vous promenez dans les capitales
européennes
vous savez que la france est affaiblie
et que nous sommes toujours sous la
menace de sanctions financières de la
connaissance pour noire des sites non
l'armée la france c'est un fait la
france est un pays qui est fort d'abord
de sa puissance diplomatique économie
que de son rayonnement culturel
oui économique parce que nous avons
parmi les plus grandes entreprises
européennes les plus grandes entreprises
mondiales dans beaucoup de domaines mais
nous avons aussi des points c'est vrai
de faiblesse oui par exemple de nos
petites et moyennes entreprises doivent
être davantage encouragées à fixer le
budget de l'état ndlr françois hollande
n'ont qu'a retenu l'injure chez nos amis
de france inter l'échec en matière de
chauffage et ils l'assument et ce qui ne
va pas de main devoir assumer son échec
en matière de déficits qui nous expose
jeu donc je le rappelle à des amendes de
la commission est ce que vous les
redoutés d'ailleurs non parce que nous
sommes engagés dans un plan de réduction
des déficits
nous avons pris une trajectoire qui est
de réduire de 50 milliards d'euros la
dépense publique à la fois pour financer
l'allègement des charges des taxations
sur les entreprises 40 milliards d'euros
pour financer aussi des mesures de
redistribution du pouvoir d'achat la
baisse par exemple des impôts pour les
ménages les plus modestes et puis pour
arrêter l'augmentation de la pression
fiscale je crois que vraiment on pouvait
pu penser régler les problèmes de cette
façon et les déficits
ils sont passés entre 2011 quand nous
sommes arrivés et vous été au-delà de 5%
et aujourd'hui ils ont baissé nous
sommes à 4,1 pour cent et nous allons
continuer à les baisser en 2015 et en
en 2010 est non nous respectons nos
engagements mais nous ne la voir aussi
on a roulé on a obtenu au delà ce qu'il
y ait une simulation sur les 3 % à ce
qu'il y ait une situation que des
traités prévoient exceptionnel où
l'inflation
vous l'avez vue est aujourd'hui à 0
qu'avait % peut-être même moins que cela
dans la zone euro puisque les chiffres
vont être publiés par exemple pour
l'allemagne c'était 0 2% au dernier
trimestre c'est quelque chose qui n'est
jamais arrivé alors que vous avez zappé
la cible de la banque centrale ces 2%
d'inflation et danse dans ces conditions
là
le principal risque c'est d'une certaine
façon un étouffement de la demande donc
nous ne voulons pas par des politiques
d'austérité nous l'avons toujours refusé
nous pensons que ça n'est pas bon pour
la zone euro par ap le mans pour notre
économie mais même pour d'autres pays
nous ne voulons pas aujourd'hui que
cette consolidation budgétaire qui est
nécessaire qui passe par la réduction de
nos dépenses se traduisent par des
politiques d'austérité qui serait bien
reste alors la harlem désir
vous parlez pas encore pour la grèce
avoue parlait toujours de la france on
va parler de la grèce dans un instant la
france et l'europe auraient de l'europe
en général dont de la grèce mais quand
même vous m'avez dit vous ne croyez pas
du tout des amendes de bruxelles dans
homo demande d'ailleurs aux pv non nous
avec celui là et c'est ce n'est pas ce
qui s'est passé
la commission européenne a considéré que
le budget que nous avions pris l'annoncé
comme nom et la discussion normale avec
la commission open qui prend en compte
pour chacun des pays
la situation de la zone euro dans son
ensemble la diminution du déficit les
réformes structurelles qui sont engagés
et c'est pourquoi nous sommes tout à
fait confiants accordant on va
poursuivre notre débat sur les taux de
la dette et des déficits avec l'europe
qui fait face donc à une possible
alternance politique en grèce avec la
gauche radicale qui est incarnée par
alexis tsipras ce la levée de boucliers
tel à berlin et à bruxelles dans gala
merkel à pierre moscovici que certains
dénoncent d'ailleurs aujourd'hui à
gauche une atteinte à la souveraineté
des peuples des peuples comme le peuple
grec qui sont essorés on le sait par des
années d'austérité car ils paieraient de
la fp dont va nous rejoindre
après ce reportage à athènes signé
jérôme rabier c'est une image qui hante
la commission européenne fait trembler
les marchés boursiers et inquiète au fmi
si le 25 janvier alexis tsipras ce le
leader de syriza sort vainqueur des
élections législatives anticipées
c'est sa coalition de gauche radicale
qui pourrait diriger le pays avec une
priorité changer de politique économique
l'austérité est un phénomène aussi
irrationnel que catastrophique pour
rembourser la dette
une restructuration sérieuse de celle ci
est nécessaire remettre en cause le
remboursement des 240 milliards d'euros
de prêts accordés par l'union européenne
le fmi et les créanciers privés depuis
quatre années
voilà le point numéro un du programme de
syriza de quoi faire sortir de leurs
gonds l'étonnant de l'austérité au
premier rang desquels l'allemagne où
angela merkel aurait évoqué une
nécessaire sortie de la zone euro en cas
de victoire de la gauche radicale
un scénario inenvisageable pour la
commission européenne d'après l'article
140 paragraphe 3 du traité
l'appartenance à l'euro est irrévocable
la sortie de l'euro n'est de toute façon
plus au programme de syriza
mais alexis tsipras ce surf sur le
ressentiment envers l'allemagne et
défient depuis longtemps angela merkel
madame merkel doit comprendre qu'elle
n'est qu'un partenaire comme les autres
au sein de l'eurozone une eurozone qui
ne connaît ni propriétaire ni locataire
ryoke tusk et niki ashton dans un pays
où le pib a perdu 25 points en quatre
ans ou 30 % de la population vit sous le
seuil de pauvreté et où le chômage
atteint 27%
ce discours fait mouche auprès des
électeurs à défaut d'autre chose
je pense que quelque chose va changer je
ne sais pas si alexis tsipras ce va
mieux s'en sortir mais cela ne sera pas
pareil pour moi c'est essentiel
après quatre années d'expérimentation il
faut changer s'il arrive à l'emporter à
constituer une majorité
alexis tsipras 40 ans et tribun hors
pair deviendra le seul interlocuteur de
l'union européenne un leader d'extrême
gauche à la table des prochains sommets
cela promet très des débats enlevée sur
la politique à mener pour sortir
l'europe de la crise vos questions à
harlem désir sur cette question cruciale
du moment
est-ce que vous même vous souhaitez vous
redoutez la victoire de syriza en grèce
le 25 janvier prochain
les grecs vont voter et ils vont choisir
librement leurs gouvernants et je crois
que tout le monde a intérêt à ce que la
grèce reste dans la zone euro y compris
les règles même et je note que toutes
les grandes formations politiques en
grèce que soient les formations
traditionnelles ou des formations
nouvelles comme syriza alexis tsipras ce
on dit qu'elle souhaitait rester dans la
zone euro à partir de là il ya plusieurs
principes d'abord il ya un principe de
démocratie la démocratie c'est ce qui
fonde l'europe donc on respecte les
choix qui vont être faits par le peuple
grec
le deuxième principe merkel mais le
deuxième principe c'est aussi que tous
les pays qui sont engagés dans l'union
économique et monétaire est d'ailleurs
dans l'europe doit respecter leurs
engagements les uns vis-à-vis des autres
et donc il y à une continuité
quelles que soient les alternances au
sein de nos pays des engagements qui
sont pris et il est évident que ces deux
principes qui définiront la relation
après des élections législatives qui va
avoir lieu en grèce entre la grèce et
ses partenaires de la zone euro
c'est-à-dire que si syriza parvenait au
pouvoir et demander une renégociation de
sa dette c'est d'ailleurs dans son
programme ça poserait ça vous poseraient
un problème
d'abord moi je n'ai pas après juger de
ce que va être le résultat d'une
élection et je crois que nous devons
être au contraire très respectueux de ce
principe démocratique qui est que chaque
peuple décide de lui même
qui sont ces dirigeants là laurent gala
merkel aux échos non pas du toit parce
que je crois qu'aucun dirigeant de
l'union européenne n'a dit qu'il
souhaitait tél
alors qu'elle disait qu'il faudrait
dit-il
si si si alexis tsipras soigner au
pouvoir il faudrait une centaine
je pense qu'il faut reprendre les
déclarations il ya une formation
politique en grèce qui est sur des
valeurs totalement contraire à celle de
l'union européenne c'est ce parti qui
s'appelle aube dorée parti néo nazi qui
d'ailleurs est impliqué dans des crimes
dont plusieurs dirigeants sont
emprisonnés et qui véritablement cje aux
enduits ce parti rien n'indique qu'il
puisse arriver au gouvernement donc quel
que soit le résultat des élections et
nous n'avons pas à nous exprimer
pour essayer d'influer je crois sur ce
résultat si ce n'est que les formations
politiques européennes sont regroupés
dans des partis européens mais en tant
que gouvernement en tant qu'exécutif
d'un des pays majeurs de l'union
européenne ne devrait très respectueux
du choix que fait chaque peuple au
moment de ces élections et en celui ci
nous avons merkel ce week-end on a parlé
d' atteinte à la démocratie il faut voir
comme vous le dis ce sont des
déclarations qui n'étaient pas vraiment
des citations et dans le reste du monde
oui mais moi pas commenter des deux
groupes je leur dit faites comme moi ne
commentait pas une élection à venir
selon nos personnages et non je dis
qu'il ya deux choses d'une part de toute
évidence il ya un débat qui a lieu au
moment de cette élection du sla thivant
en grèce et kiki et on le voit aussi
dans le climat d'une politique qui a été
très dur après une crise qui a mené à
des mesures d'austérité
mais cette situation la grèce si et
trouvez aussi parce qu'elle-même serbe
est pas bien gérer ses comptes publics
que les déficits avait explosé et que
donc il a fallu qu'il y ait un
dispositif de soutien à la fois
européens et du fonds monétaire
international vérité dire que la grèce
est d'abord victime de ses dirigeants
passés plus que de l'europe aujourd'hui
qui est venu à son secours
en tout cas je crois que toutes les
formations politiques aujourd'hui en
grèce considère qu'il ya des réformes
qui doivent être faites par exemple en
matière de fiscalité en matière de
cadastre en matière de bonne gestion de
l'administration et cela ce n'est pas
donc l'europe qui en soi l'imposent
c'est la situation comme dans chacun de
nos pays
si les finances publiques ne sont pas
bien gérés
certain nombre de réformes qui doivent
être faites par ailleurs je vais donc
que nous soyons très respectueux du
choix que va faire un peuple et dont on
ne doit pas préjuger c'est pas les
sondages qui font le résultat d'une
élection on le sait donc attendons que
ces élections aient eu lieu le 25
janvier et après ton nous à travailler
avec le futur gouvernement grec comme
nous avons travaillé avec les précédents
gouvernements grecs cette formation
syriza réclament la tenue d'une grande
conférence européenne sur sur la dette
est ce qu'on peut imaginer que un jour
autour d'une même table tous les
dirigeants européens se retrouvent pour
rediscuter de d'un rééchelonnement d'un
effacement peut-être partiel ou dans le
sol de la dette
et est ce que par exemple la france y
est prête sachant que serait un coût
pour le contribuable français
on parle de milliards d'euros ou encore
une fois ça supposerait de rentrer dans
l'hypothèse que l'on connaît le résultat
l'action elle retient c'est que je ne
peux pas faire de la politique fiction
parce que encore une fois ce sont les
citoyens qui vont s'exprimer en grèce
ils vont décider leur culture galement
et ce futur gouvernement quel qu'il soit
va continuer à discuter avec les autres
états membres et avec la commission
européenne des conditions de sortie de
la grèce de la crise dans laquelle elle
est et en même temps du plan daide elle
a eu besoin d'une haine là on a encore
besoin je crois et donc la solidarité
c'est aussi un principe européen auquel
nous sommes très attachés
mais encore une fois quand il ya la
solidarité il ya aussi le respect c'est
comme vous l'avez dit les autres pays se
sont portés au secours de la grèce
l'allemagne tous les pays et l'italie
même l'espagne même les pays qui étaient
eux mêmes en difficulté se sont portés
au secours de la grèce et donc il est
normal que chacun soit attentif à ce que
ensuite il y ait la possibilité d'une
sortie de cette crise dans laquelle a
été car il vient de citer un chiffre
très important c'est l'exposition de la
france à la dette grecque
un défaut de paiement qu'outre et séguy
faire hochstatt
l'un des leaders centristes du parlement
qui le dit coûterait 40 9 milliards
coûterait 40 9 milliards d'euros pour
les français
mais d'abord je veux pas qu'on fasse des
plans catastrophique une réalité
comptable mais écoutez notre objectif il
a toujours été de préserver l'unité et
la stabilité de la zone euro et la
france s'est battue pour que soit mis en
oeuvre le mécanisme européen de
stabilité qu'une sorte de fmi européen
qui doit éviter que se reproduisent qui
s'est passé pendant la crise de 2007
2008 c'est à dire qu'à partir d'une
crise bancaire et de la crise de
défaillance de quelques états membres du
problème de la grèce mais il y en a eu
d'autres y lire landes il puisse y avoir
ce qu'on appelle une crise systémique
c'est à dire une déstabilisation qui se
propage dans l'ensemble du système
financier et donc de l'économie de la
zone euro donc nous avons mis en place
ces mécanismes de stabilité et c'est
pourquoi aussi nous avons refusé ce que
d'autres proposaient un moment qui était
l'idée de dire bah pour régler après la
crise on n'a qu'à se débarrasser des
pays qui sont en difficulté laisser
sortir de la zone euro des pays comme la
grèce qui sont difficiles et nous
l'avons refusée parce que c'est un
projet politique l'euro c'est le
exactement donc il faut continuer à
tenir cette ligne là l'euro s'est hissé
construction c'est que les collègues
lozère hauteur de 49,9 avant selon guy
verhofstadt à la dette grecque
et vous pensez que c'est un coup que
nous pourrions supporter vu notre
situation que je ne me place pas du tout
à l'hypothèse où il y aurait là où il y
aurait une sortie peut se passer il y
aura une sortie d'un pays de la zone
euro et comme l'a dit le président de la
république ce sont les grecs d'abord qui
doivent décider s'ils veulent ou non
rester dans la zone euro je constate que
toutes les grandes formations politiques
encore une fois à qu'elle soit de droite
de gauche nouvelles ou anciennes y
compris syriza disent qu'elles veulent
rester dans la zone euro et je crois que
l'expression des grecs on ne sait pas ce
que sera le résultat de l'élection mais
va confirmer que majoritairement ils
auront voté pour des formations
politiques qui souhaitent que la grèce
reste dans la zone euro donc à partir de
là nous allons étude nous allons il faut
toujours de travailler sur la base de
principes
ça veut dire que nous allons travailler
à ce que la grèce qui est en train de
progressivement se remettre
de remettre en ordre ses finances
publiques puissent être accompagnés dans
ce plan de sortie de crise et de
solidarité dont elle a été bénéficiaire
en vo échos quand même vous dites qu'il
faut que la grèce poursuive son
programme de réformes donc finalement
vous préfériez qu'il n'ya pas
d'alternance entre radioshack
gouvernement peut mener les réformes à
sa façon et vous dites il faut matinée
mais il dit il faut continuer à réformer
et bien entendu le livre continue et à
désendetter les finances publiques mais
ça je crois que personne ne le conteste
pas même series a ensuite la façon de
mener sérieux remonte tous les minima
sociaux si on augmente et salers ont
commencé à embaucher des fonctionnaires
embaucher des fonctionnaires oui mais
c'est pas le programme de réformes que
vous défendez messali parce que si en
même temps vous avez une réforme des
recettes fiscales si vous faites en
sorte que toutes les institutions qui ne
paient pas d'impôts jusqu'à présent dans
ce pays en paye vous savez qu'il y avait
beaucoup trop il y avait beaucoup de
d'évasion fiscale
bon ben vous pouvez aussi assainir les
finances publiques en menant des
politiques différentes
qu'est ce que vous pensez des propos de
pierre moscovici qui donc est allé aussi
à athènes pour en quelque sorte dire
enfin pour dire qu'il est qu'il fallait
un large soutien des électeurs envers
les réformes prévues il a pas hésité lui
à s'engager oui je crois qu'il faut pas
donner une mauvaise interprétation
puisque lui-même a dit que la commission
européenne n'avait pas à se mêler de
l'élection en grèce et donc elle ne
donnait pas de consigne de vote il a
voulu apporter je crois un message de
solidarité de soutien à la grèce la
commission européenne je crois l'a dit
très clairement aujourd'hui il n'ya pas
d'option sur une sortie d'un pays de la
zone euro et donc tout le monde
travaille à ce que la grèce reste bien
dans la zone euro il donne aussi des
leçons à la france lui qui a été
ministre de l'économie on l'a entendu
dire récemment aujourd'hui l'objectif
budgétaire n'est pas rempli je crois
qu'il a fait une déclaration qui était
quand même plus équilibré que cela à mes
objectifs et a comme objectif était
clair l'objectif budgétaire à venir à
paris à bruxelles
notre objectif budgétaire c'est
évidemment de diminuer les déficits et
de diminuer la dette en france nous le
faisons pas parce que simplement il y
aurait des règles européennes nous le
faisons nous l'avons dit parce que nous
voulons retrouver des marges de
manoeuvre
et parce que on n'a pas handicapé
l'avenir en accumulant des dettes
quand nous sommes arrivés en 2012 la
dette avait doublé en l'espace d'un
quinquennat celui de nicolas sarkozy
elles avaient été augmentées de 600
milliards d'euros elles avaient été
augmentées de 1000 milliards d'euros en
l'espace de dix ans nous voulons mettre
un coup d'arrêt à une politique qui
était totalement irresponsable et donc
nous le faisons parce que nous pensons
que c'est plus intéressant de consacrer
des moyens à l'éducation à la loi de
transition énergétique à investir dans
l'avenir que à payer les intérêts de la
dette stone
autre sujet mais qui concerne aussi
l'allemagne allait confronté un
mouvement anti-islam à ce que c'est
quelque chose qui vous inquiète
oui ce mouvement comme il en existe dans
d'autres pays européens
évidemment c'est quelque chose qui doit
nous mobiliser et je me réjouis que la
chancelière angela merkel et beaucoup
d'autres personnalités politiques de
tous bords confondus d'ailleurs en
allemagne et condamnés avec une très
grande fermeté ce mouvement xénophobe et
anti islam et qu'il y ait eu des contre
manifestations des manifestations plus
en plus nombreuse positive pour dire que
l'allemagne n'accepterait pas de voir ce
ce mouvement l'emporter et la
chancelière a eu des mots très forts et
elle a montré par là d'ailleurs ce qui
était la force des valeurs démocratiques
que nous avons en commun en europe et
dans toutes les périodes de crise il ya
toujours cette tendance cette tentation
de populisme de désigner des boucs
émissaires de ça existe sous des formes
différentes dans beaucoup de pays de
l'union européenne parce que nous sommes
confrontés à des difficultés un chômage
à une crise et c'est facile de désigner
les étrangers ou une catégorie de
population une religion comme
responsable nous ne pouvons pas
l'accepter et par exemple en allemagne
il ya eu des responsables pour faire
remarquer que c'était d'autant plus
aberrant que l'allemagne pour des
raisons démographiques avait besoin
aujourd'hui de ces étrangers
qu'ils viennent dans ce pays pour
travailler en allemagne a pas le même
problème de chômage que chez nous donc
on peut pas accuser les étrangers qui
sont dans ce pays d'être soi disant
responsables d'un problème d'emploi par
exemple et pourtant on voit qu'il ya
quand même des mouvements populistes
c'est une question de valeurs c'est une
question de principe et face à cela il
faut s'appuyer sur les valeurs
fondamentales de chacun de nos pays pour
nous ce sont les valeurs de la
république en allemagne c'est les
valeurs démocratiques qui ont permis de
reconstruire l'allemagne après la guerre
pour refuser ces mouvements démagogique
et pour vous le nouveau roman de michel
à louer avec soumission participent ce
populisme et de ses peurs que vous
évoquez j'ai pas eu l'occasion d'avoir
lu en son nom par ailleurs il ya une
liberté de création et d'écriture
document du gouvernement
mais ce que je veux dire c'est qu'en
tout cas on ne peut pas vivre dans la
peur du changement ou dans la peur de
l'autre et que la france c'est un pays
qui a toujours été capable justement de
surmonter mais pas peur de
l'islamisation de la société vaut mais
non seulement j'en ai pas peur mais
c'est une absurdité et je crois qu'au
contraire nous devons nous appuyer sur
ce qui est le coeur même de l'identité
de la nation républicaine qui est fondée
sur des valeurs universelles et qui lui
a toujours permis d'intégrer par la
citoyenneté celles et ceux qui sont
venus d'ailleurs et qui font partie
aujourd'hui la de la force notre les
démentir michel houellebecq dans le
nouvel obs tard l'ops cette semaine qui
dit la république est morte la laïcité
est morte
les lumières resteront une parenthèse
dans l'histoire mais je crois que la
france au contraire elle incarne
toujours les lumières et que c'est y
compris en s'inspirant toujours de cette
part-là de son histoire qu'elle réussit
à rayonner et que aujourd'hui ce qui
donne du sens à ce que nous faisons
c'est aussi de permettre à la france de
continuer à porter dans le monde et en
europe ses valeurs celles des lumières
merci car et une perrine tarneaud arrive
donc pour évoquer le ps je le disais
vous avez dû céder les rênes de
solférino à jean christophe cambadélis
il ya un peu moins d'un an maintenant
c'était après l'échec des municipales
mais votre fixés sur lui est exposé à
deux échecs potentiel puisqu'il parle de
scrutin un peu rude à venir chaque
potentiel sinon inévitable de cette
année louis sybille dur dur d'être
socialiste en 2015
l'année s'annonce d'ores et déjà
difficile la machine de guerre du parti
peine à recruter des candidats pour les
élections départementales de mars
prochain rouge c'est le cas en moselle
par exemple le premier secrétaire a même
dû envoyer une lettre aux adhérents pour
trouver des candidats
je comprends vos interrogations sur tel
ou tel aspect de la politique
gouvernementale mais il ne faut pas
baisser les bras
le parti tente de minimiser les
difficultés dans des moments et dans des
territoires je le redis où la gauche
connaît parce que la droite y est très
forte
de nombreuses défaites électorales le
fait qu'on ait dans ces endroits là et
ils sont nombreux plus de difficultés
qu'avant à trouver des candidats
c'est quelque chose d'assez normal les
départementales des élections déjà
annoncé comme une débâcle pour le
pouvoir
or deux mois plus tard se tient le temps
fort du ps le congrès du parti
avec cette question explosive en
filigrane faut-il suivre la ligne
sociale libérale du gouvernement les
frondeurs annonce déjà vouloir déposer
une motion contre l'austérité
a priori toute une série de gens qui se
sont retrouvés dans les fondeurs sont au
moins d'accord sur la critique de ce qui
est menée nous en tout cas on mènera
cette bataille on souhaite qu'elles
rassemblent le plus grand
nombre possible et surtout qu'il y ait
une majorité de socialistes qui prennent
leurs responsabilités pour dire on doit
changer de cap
l'exécutif est clairement dans le
collimateur le premier secrétaire lui
préfère rester prudent je ne pense pas
que l'objectif du congrès soit de
renverser le gouvernement ce serait un
peu paradoxal pour un parti socialiste
2015 annus horribilis derniers temps
forts les élections régionales se
tiendront en décembre
là encore les pronostics ne sont pas
bons dos en perspective de ce congrès du
mois de juin pour le parti social et
c'est ce qui est un risque réel
d'explosion du parti selon vous je ne
crois pas moi je suis en charge des
questions européennes au sein du
gouvernement aujourd'hui donc je pas vos
questions à commenter mais je suis
socialiste et je pense que les
socialistes
je ne souhaite en tout cas auront la
sagesse se rassembler largement autour
d'une motion d'un texte de d'appui à
l'action du président de la république
et du premier ministre mais par le
premier secrétaire jean christophe
cambadélis
parce que je crois que les socialistes
doivent être fiers de ce qu'ils font
c'est vrai que nous arrivons souvent aux
responsabilités dans des situations
difficiles contre le pays est en crise
et nous avons à la fois redresser la
situation du pays et en même temps on
attend de la gauche qu'elle fasse aussi
progressé des droits des avancées
démocratiques et sociales et c'est pas
facile mais c'est quand même ce que nous
sommes en train de faire parce que nous
sommes à marianne socialistes ne sont
pas du tout fier de ce travail là ils se
font entendre on les appelle les
frondeurs
et bien tout à l'heure j'ai évoqué
moi je me souviens et je suis pas le
seul parce que le président de la
république nous l'a rappelé récemment le
nombre de fois où dans notre histoire
comme socialiste nous avons signé des
textes en disant il faut donner à tous
les travailleurs de ce pays un droit à
la formation tout au long de la vie et
de leur carrière
et bien maintenant nous avons créé ce
compte formation le nombre de fois où
nous disions pour qu'une réforme des
retraites soit juste il faut qu'elles
puissent prendre en compte la pénibilité
en particulier pour les ouvriers pour
ceux qui sont exposés à des risques qui
mettent en cause leur espérance de vie
eh bien nous venons de faire entrer dans
la loi nombre de fois où nous disions il
faut que l'école redevienne la priorité
dans la première manche il est quand
même nous nous avons refait dribble
disent que c'est insuffisant
je connais ce que cela a été fait et
j'aimerais que tous en tout cas
l'assument avec avec fierté
mais c'est vrai que nous nous nous avons
repris la responsabilité des pays du
pays dans une situation de crise crise
de la zone euro crise internationale
aussi retard industriel nous avions
perdu beaucoup de positions tout à
l'heure je disais que la france est un
pays qui peut être fier de ses très
grandes entreprises soulignait aussi
difficultés de nos petites et moyennes
entreprises
quand nous sommes arrivés déficit du
commerce commercial 75 ricardo
l'héritage je parle de l'immensité de la
tâche le premier ministre l'a dit
lui-même dans l'interview à laquelle
vous faisait référence
un journal espagnol el mundo ça sera
long et en même temps c'est en train de
produire ses effets y'a un indice qui
est paru aujourd'hui sur sur sur les
intentions des entreprises
'l'indice pmi concert des directeurs
d'achat pour la première fois cet indice
est en train de repasser au seuil qui
qui est celui de la croissance c'est à
dire où il ya des intentions
d'investissement cessna convaincre non
seulement les frondeurs au congrès du
parti socialiste mais également les
électeurs puisque à deux échéances
importantes cette année notamment
d'avoir les élections départementales au
mois de mars
on attend une défaite historique du
parti socialiste c'est aussi votre
pronostic
d'abord il faut pas aller à un rendez
vous électoral en disant par avance on
attend
résultat qui est pas favorable il faut y
aller mais non mais d'accord c'est
distant et social il y à il ya une
situation économique qui est difficile
en même temps les présidents de
départements
la majorité d'entre eux sont de gauche
et socialistes ils ont un bon bilan
en général ils sont appréciés de leurs
concitoyens ce qui va être en jeu c'est
de renouveler leur mandat avec les
conseillers départementaux pour les six
prochaines années pour qu'ils soient au
service du développement de leur
territoire de la solidarité puisque
c'est notamment la compétence des
départements deuxièmement intimiste
deuxièmement je crois que les
socialistes ont intérêt pendant cette
campagne a assumé et à faire la
pédagogie de l'action qu'il mène aussi
au niveau gouvernemental
parce que effectivement les électeurs
ils vont d'abord avoir à choisir des
élus départementaux mais comme
l'élection a lieu le même jour dans tout
le pays
ce sera aussi une élection politique et
on ne peut pas gagner une bataille
électorale
si on n'y va pas en disant qu'on est
fier de l'action qu'on mène et des
progrès qu'on permet aux pays drainage
est aussi fière d'être socialiste enfin
vous parlez beaucoup de fierté n'a
jamais été aussi fier d'être social est
en tout cas que nous devons être fiers
oui moi je suis très fier de ce que nous
faisons sur le plan du redressement de
l'économie du pays des progrès sociaux
et sur le plan européen et international
moi je suis fier c'est vrai quand je
vois le président de la république
allait reprendre l'initiative pour
régler la crise avec la russie et vous
savez qu'aujourd'hui il y à un processus
qu'on appelle format normandie où la
france a remis en dialogue la russie
l'ukraine avec notre partenaire
l'allemagne il ya des discussions qui se
mêlent de tout toutes les semaines il va
y avoir une réunion des ministres des
affaires étrangères et coran fabius et
le président de la république lui-même a
dit sa disponibilité à reprendre le
chemin encore d'une réunion qui pourrait
avoir lieu pour que les présidents russe
et mercredi un signe la paix là je suis
fier quand je vois que j'attends c'est
les mêmes désirs parce que les électeurs
ne sont pas forcément convaincu mais
aussi vous allez
du parti socialiste je pense au vert je
pense parti communiste tout le monde va
partir en ordre dispersé pour ces
élections départementales du mois de
mars
et du coup ça va être difficile de
sauver les mêmes noms malgré votre
optimisme non vous avez raison vous avez
raison sur ce point c'est que si la
gauche se présente à ces élections avec
une multiplicité de candidatures au
premier tour elle se rend les choses
plus difficiles parce qu'on peut
toujours dire on se rassemblera au
second tour mais enfin il n'y a rien
il vaut mieux arriver à se qualifier
pour le second tour que quel que soit le
mode de scrutin et l'élection
et il vaut mieux déjà créé une dynamique
au premier tour surtout que dans les
départements puisqu'on parle là des
élections départementales comme des
élections régionales qui auront lieu
ensuite à la fin de l'année nous
gouvernons ensemble avec les autres
formations de gauche avec les
écologistes en particulier
c'est ensemble que nous animons ces
collectivités locales est que nous avons
un bilan commun qu en général
tous sont fiers de défense et manuel
valls qui nous a peut-être pas facilité
la tâche je fais référence à son
interview dans le nouvel obs à l'automne
dernier quand il avait attaqué la gauche
passéiste qui l'avait évoqué la fin du
parti socialiste
mais manuel valls d'abord lui-même a été
un élu local pendant dix ans il a été
maire d'evry il a gouverné avec toute la
gauche aujourd'hui à chacun des grands
textes qu'il a eu l'occasion de
présenter récemment avec ségolène royal
le texte sur la transition énergétique
il a cherché à rassembler la majorité et
il l'a fait et il y a eu de sa volonté
les oeufs de sa part la volonté de
rassembler et je crois qu'aujourd'hui
chacun y compris chez les écologistes
réfléchit effectivement à la façon dont
on peut le mieux préparé ces scrutins
locaux
vous évoquez les élections régionales il
y a beaucoup d'élus qui sont en place et
qui sont en place déjà depuis trois
mandats qui souhaite repartir pour un
quatrième mandat je peux les citer jean
paul huchon alain rousset martin malvy
michel vauzelle est les 198 ils sont là
oui trois mandats samedi 18 ans est-ce
qu'ils sont légitimes à repartir pour un
quatrième mandat
d'abord lancé s'ils sont là c'est que
les électeurs ont souhaité les
reconduire et en général c'est parce que
ils ont incarné très bien
leur territoire le développement de ces
régions vous avez mentionné alain
rousset par exemple je suis allé
récemment en aquitaine parce que il ya
là-bas des équipements qui sont
cofinancés avec l'europe
je pense par exemple à l'aérocampus qui
est un endroit où sont formés des jeunes
pour les métiers de l'aéronautique en
commun avec les industries nautiques
françaises allemandes à jambi méchants
socialistes ce nombre de mandat de
présidence d'exécutif était limité à
trois mois je suis en charge la partie
socialiste mais je crois que c'est les
électeurs qui ont souhaité que ces
présidents de région continue ensuite il
ya des désignations au sein de chaque
formation politique y en aura donc tout
sépare du parti c'est à dire il faut
choisir chaque fois le candidat qui est
le mieux à même d'en connaître plus en
charge du parti socialiste qu'elle vous
avez subi des attaques assez violente
quand on vous avait dû céder les rênes
du parti il ya un peu moins d'un an
est ce que vous êtes insensible aux
attaques comme françois hollande d'abord
quand vous êtes responsable d'une
formation politique vous êtes toujours
l'objet d'attaqués ça fait partie de la
vie politique semble-t-il
moi j'essaye de plus nous préoccuper du
fonds geci le montrer dans notre échange
c'est à dire des politiques que nous
menons au service des français au
service du pays et je pense qu'il faut
il faut relativiser discret depuis votre
arrivée au ministère des affaires
européennes non je viens un peu on m'a
dit simplement parce que je vais pas
exister entre matignon et l'elysée
laurent fabius oui d'abord c'est quand
même avec qui je travaille très bien et
que j'ai cités u notamment pour son
action pour la crise en ukraine et en
russie mais parce que je passe beaucoup
de temps dans les réunions européennes
allaient rencontrer mes homologues dans
les autres pays à négocier pour défendre
les positions de la france pour faire
évoluer l'europe vers de nouvelles
priorités parce que l'enjeu de l'année
2015 c'est que l'europe soit plus
synonyme d'austérité mais qu'elle soit
synonyme de croissance d'investissement
d'où l'importance du plan juncker dont
j'aurais aimé qu'on va voir d'avantagé
que nous avons faits rapportés et qui va
maintenant devoir entrer en vigueur pour
que des projets il qu'on l'attend tout
sur la violence on l'attend au ce
féculent moi ça passe de mines et des
affaires urbaines rap à vue de
rencontrer le pape françois il paraît
que vous avez été très impressionné par
sa visite au parlement européen est
séduit oui c'est vrai j'ai été
impressionné par sa personnalité par les
discours qu'il a pu tenir devant le
parlement européen et le conseil de
l'europe mais aussi par la force qui se
dégage sa personnalité je crois que
c'est un pape révolutionnaire qui est
bien dans une enceinte parlementaire il
ya eu des critiques je pense à jean luc
mélenchon par exemple non d'abord il
était invité du parlement européen le
pape fera je crois aussi une visite en
france cette année ce ne sera pas la
première fois mais c'est toujours un
grand événement et il représente à la
fois une force spirituelle et en même
temps un état
l'état du vatican et je crois que la wii
c'est vrai qu'il a hérité très jeune en
parlant de l'europe et en disant
notamment une chose qui nous a dit avec
ségolène royal quand nous l'avons
accueillie vous avez eu un entretien
avec lui d'une façon peut être encore
plus fort ce que dans le discours c'est
que l'europe doit pas être une grand
mère qu'elle doit redevenir une mère
c'est à dire être très jeune
corps les curiosités s'enthousiasme
philippe tesson dans le besoin a fait
l'analogie entre les discours du pape et
les discours de françois mais françois
hollande jugeant ce sont des
incantations
je me garderai bien de faire des
comparaisons mais je crois que vous
venez dans deux ordres différents mais
nous nous sommes dans l'action et
président de la république françois
hollande est bien dans l'action on en
arrive à chiots pendant ce mois donc des
discours de parts
merci arte mais avertit karine bonsoir à
tous et à la semaine prochaine
conte